cher journal j'ai encore fait une
insomnie
j'ai pas réussi à fermer l'oeil de la
nuit tout ça parce que j'ai repensé à
cet entretien d'embauché ou j'ai voulu
faire une blague qui n'a pas du tout
fonctionné
je vous préviens je suis pas là pour
coucher je rigole pas un stimulant non
voilà je voulais juste montrer que
j'étais un petit peu rugueux là tu
voulais faire bonne impression mais puis
j'ai repensé à toutes ces fois où un
serveur m'a dit bon appétit et que je
lui ai répondu à vous aussi
et cette fois où j'ai dérangé une
actrice connue pour lui dire que j'étais
fan et que je me suis même pas rendu
compte qu'elle était en plein drame
familial je comprends pas ce que tu dis
là
comment s'est opérée en urgence
t'es sûr suffisamment à temps
je voulais juste vous dire je suis une
grande fan j'ai vu tous les films
j'adore ce que vous faites là c'est le
grand pardon
surtout dans le film mortels banalité je
vous ai trouvé extraordinaire vous étiez
incroyable enfin vraiment vous m'avez
marqué je voulais vous dire ok eh ben tu
me tiens au courant d'accord si ça vous
dérangerait qu'une classe 1 seule fille
oui
macha
[Musique]
[Rires]
il y eut cette fois aux mondiaux a
glissé de la touche b à la touche b sur
mon clavier mais qu'ils m'ont quand même
rappeler pour un second entretien non je
sais qu'il est un quiproquo l'aide d'un
art fois quand j'ai dit que je rigolais
ça pouvait laisser sous entendre que
j'étais là pour coucher avec vous si
c'est pour ça que vous m'avez rappeler
je préfère vous le dire tout de suite je
suis pas désespéré ait un accord enfin
je ne dis pas que je serai désespérer de
coucher avec vous un espace pas du tout
ça que je dis je parle de désespoir de
trouver un emploi pas de se passer la
désespérée que j'avais vous vous êtes
très bien enfin les pattes je pourrais
couché avec vous j'ai ans rencontré dans
un autre contexte boivin
j'ai tellement que j'ai encore envie de
me cacher alors que je suis chez moi et
que ma personne ne me voit j'aimerais
trouver le courage d'appeler tous ces
gens pour m'excuser mais en réalité je
crois que je risquerais surtout de le
rappeler un truc qui longe espère
oublier
allô oui bonjour je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de moi j'avais passé des
entretiens et quelques temps et je
voulais oui oui c'est ça c'est moi ouais
à vous souvenez d'accord ok est-ce que
non seulement on pourrait convenir d'un
nouveau rendez vous puisque je suis
toujours très motivé je ouais super
nickel bas très bien ça marche merci
beaucoup au revoir
bisous j'ai dit biz ou non
[Musique]